as far as the drought that seems to be
what everybody's talking about right now
ironically I don't know if people can
see if you have a couple of drips on you
because it is actually oh my god yes it
is it's not sweat it's not flop sweat
but it's raining employee are actually
excited and we are in the midst of well
tell us a little bit about the drought
because we've done some stories on it
it's bad I mean it's a very bad drought
there's been very few years in the long
history of measuring water measuring
water in LA it's been worse than this we
had a year that was three and a half
inches about 1920 something I think I
look back that the history of LA
rainfall this past year has been
seven-and-a-half inches before what we
just got today when I hear the news
tonight we'll know what it is maybe 7
3/4 or 8 inches that's a very bad year
yeah
average normal is 15 or 16 inches so we
have to do something we've been wasting
water by washing our cars out in the
driveway well guilty of it yeah
everybody growing these lush lawns or
what have you in a Mediterranean
ecosystem you know a semi-arid grassland
is what this is technically and it is
very dry here
the only reason la has survived an out
all these lawns and all these this
prosperity is because we got our straw
dipped in somebody else's drink a lot of
the people along the Colorado River like
maybe oh let's say Colorado we'd like to
you know hold onto some of that water
and in Arizona and what-have-you
everybody wants a piece of it and then
the other one is the California Aqueduct
that takes water from the San Joaquin
Delta so those three legs to the stool
of the only thing that keeps us from
falling over and if one of them gets a
little wobbly we're gonna have real
trouble do you think people actually
understand the severity of this no
because I just read a story this week
that ethos which is the company that
Starbucks hire yes bottled water from
there moving out of California because
there's not enough water here good for
them what do we have to do to actually
get people to wake up because you know
it's one of those things where it's like
it happens so slowly that people don't
really realize where they think well my
lawns all right I'll still keep going
right what what do you do to kind of
really slap people in the face with it I
don't know that you can do any more than
every water agency every news broadcast
practically everybody every newspaper is
doing the illusion is this right here
hey I want some water here we go hmm
it's available you turn on the tap and
it comes out so we think it's all going
to last forever
yeah we're near the end we're heading
towards a cliff now
because what has recharged the aquifers
that they're going deeper and deeper
with water bottling plants and
agriculture the the solution the problem
would just go deeper and deeper
that's our bank account your draining
your bank account to nothing you get a
paycheck at some point to replenish that
bank account
there's no payday now because there's no
Sierra snowpack that's what we're up
against and people I'm afraid I kept if
we had this conversation a month ago no
we're gonna get to them we're gonna let
them know somehow and maybe we are but I
don't know what it's gonna take you
can't let people know anymore there's
people in my neighborhood that still
have these lush lawns so sprinklers are
on in the rain in the rain you come to
see the sprinklers on which now is a
violation and it should be so I've been
seeing these stories pop up on Gawker
and some of these sites where they're
now they're trying to publicly shame
some of these people you know they
listed a bunch of celebrities with big
lush lawns but isn't that just a tiny
portion of it isn't this real like the
real usage is really from probably
industrial stuff right and golf courses
and things like that like the
residential stuff even though I guess it
gets headlines isn't that everybody's
got to come to the party residential as
part of it but you're right it's much
smaller the notion of growing rice and
almonds on the western side the San
Joaquin Valley is just I think it's just
foolhardy we had the illusion that it
was gonna be okay for yours because we
had excess all these people that say
I've got a ticket in line for my water
it's a law you can't take it from me I'm
an almond grower I grow rice I grow
broccoli I grow without the people who
grow broccoli and lettuce can go well
okay I'm not getting my allotment the
way I used to I'll leave it fallow for a
year and get a theta state of federal
tax credit for doing the good thing but
what do you do with a nama tree you
can't leave it fallow these people have
their ticket in line all of these
tickets in line for water in California
are based on excess nearly all of them
yeah there's very few that aren't based
on excess from the San Joaquin Delta
there's been no excess for years it's
this illusion that people in residential
neighborhoods people in agriculture
everybody thinks because they somehow
turn on a tap and come down magically
can they point the finger at you no they
did finger at environmentalists we're
doing like causing this like we're the
ones doing it that's like blaming the
smoke detector company for the fire yeah
you know we didn't start this fire we're
just trying to save whatever species we
can
San Joaquin you know in the San
Francisco Bay Delta certain species of
fish are like Canaries in the coal mine
that's for all of us
you can't dry up all the water you can't
suck a triangle how did that happen you
know we know we can see it coming what's
the silver lining here is it that
technology is gonna save us is it going
to be we're going to start rebuilding
desalinization plants is that that is it
that the conservation will work or have
we crossed that threshold where even if
we cut back we're still behind the eight
ball what do you like all desal should
be the last thing on your list that's
when you're really people are you know
standing in line like you know Blade
Runner kind of life you know people are
in real trouble dying thirst and
what-have-you
so is it not efficient that's where
people's already takes a lot of Energy's
your mass amount of energy you know how
people go all you got left is table-saw
that's salt it's not quite table salt
where do you put it you can't really
easily and reintroduce it in the marine
environment without hurting a lot of
species you know because it's such a
concentration of salt and other minerals
so there's a problem with that and
there's a lot of energy but there's much
cheaper ways let's just follow the money
and the economy of it if we collected
our rainwater really collected
efficiently in two important ways people
doing it the way I did it for years poor
man's rainwater capture sawed off with
the hacksaw your downspout put a barrel
under it put it up on some block so you
can get to the spigot at the bottom and
you're gonna collect your rainwater for
like 80 bucks a barrel or whatever they
charge for them now you can get them
online and I think they're 80 bucks for
a barrel or something like that
they're discount ones where people
recycle old olive oil barrels or
something yeah get those even cheaper so
do that number one number two people
have more resources which I do I'm
building a LEED Platinum all my pretty
10,000 gallon rainwater tank on the
ground 10,000 gallons that will surely
take care of all my irrigation needs
from the last rain in May to the first
rain in October that's the other one and
the most important one to break up a lot
of the way we've concrete ties you know
we've paved over places like la more
permeable surfaces so the water can go
down to the water table well that's
exactly where I wanted to end the
conversation about the drought because
that is exactly what we do here we try
to let you guys know you can do
something with the new so not only the
government's doing things but there's
things that you yourself can do anyway
what do you think is
is the drought as bad as it seems are
you doing anything let us know in the
comments write down